how did you feel getting your first role
or how how was that feeling when you
were just like
man i'm actually like achieving my dream
right now
well um we had an audition to get that
role
and um i knew that it was like like
an english-speaking character like the
audition was like you had to speak in
english
right like just anything in english and
so um
yeah there was like other people um that
were like auditioning as well
and i was like i'm the one that's like
that can talk english
excuse me are you ego josue i don't
think so i don't think so
i was like oh if i don't get this role
i'm gonna like maybe this is not like
you just turned up and you're like oh
i've got this
but then um yeah like when i heard that
i got the role i was like super happy
because
obviously not many people who are still
in school get
a job yeah yeah um and you know a lot of
people
um even after they like graduate they
don't get
you know jobs right yeah so just like
normal university
and so like i was like i was super happy
because i
like you know because my first job was
conquered like contact collection
and that was like a huge game as well so
yeah i was just like my first job is
concur like oh like oh my god
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's so cool
i mean did you like parents find out
about it too like did you tell them or
i told them but um they're they're
they're not really
like into anime and stuff so they're
like oh really
that's nice
enjoy wildlife yeah yeah yeah yeah wait
so how do parents feel about what you do
now then
um well um now they're um they're like
more accepting and they're kind of like
you know yeah yeah because they're
starting to see
like yeah yeah yeah results yeah when
you get a stable income parents always
like all right
maybe this isn't too bad yeah yeah yeah
that's literally almost like for my
parents as well because they were like
when i was still doing it at home
during uni the whole youtube thing they
were like you have fun with that while
last you know it's like it's
that's a good pain you got there and
then when my dad was like
you make more than i do her mom that's
when he was finally like
i'll allow it thanks dad
like do your parents know kind of what
you do now do they understand at least
what you do
yeah like um uh my sister she she
she kind of she kind of shows like what
i do to my parents
right so like um yeah they they kind of
now
know what that's good do they do that
thing where like wait this is you
yeah they
like i remember when i first like tried
to explain what my job to my parents
were like
what are you how would you make money
off this i don't understand this youtube
thing
and then like cut to like three years
later my dad like phones me up and being
like
i was checking your social blade and
your last video seems to be
underperformed
what's going on with that
it's a transition from not knowing
anything
like anything to suddenly be like an
analyst right
i'm like you you gained 100 less
subscribers than on average for this day
what's going on are you are you paying
enough attention that's like still cute
though
because like my parents are definitely
not that like i think my parents are
kind of
they went from not knowing or caring to
kind of being like
caring but still not really knowing you
know like
i think when i ask my dad like what he
thinks about what i do for a job
he was just like oh you know i don't
support it i just let you do it
i mean for like youtubers i guess it's
really hard to explain to your parents
like
what kind of job it is true true yeah i
guess for a while
you can just say i'm an actor you just
show them a clip and
be like that me
my grandma to this day still thinks i'm
a comedian
because that's the only way i can
explain it to my grandma who's like yeah
your grandson is a comedian that's just
not on tv and she's like
oh wow okay very good sweet